j'ai eu de la chance alors avec un peu
d'ironie et pas mal de guinéens quand
même parce que je m'en serais bien passé
mais disons que j'ai eu de la chance
parce que j'ai eu le bon viol en fait ce
que je veux dire c'est que le viol c'est
hallucinant à quel point on sait tous au
fond que le viol se pratique partout à
tous les étages de la société tout le
temps et depuis la nuit des temps et en
même temps comme on refuse de le penser
comme on refuse de l'admettre
parce que ça fait appel à des terreurs
tellement enfouis qu'on se dit qu'on vit
mieux en mettant un couvercle dessus ce
qui est totalement faux
parce que le déni n'a jamais sauvé
personne au contraire ça flingue le déni
mais bref on est dans un impensé total
et dans cet impensé il ya parce que
depuis 50 ans il ya le travail des
féministes de génération après
génération
elles ont fini par ouvrir une petite
fenêtre la petite fenêtre de
l'envisageable et du concevable
c'est le viol qui ait commis de nuit sur
un parking avec une arme
et là on se dit que oui peut-être
éventuellement éventuellement ça a pu se
produire
moi j'ai subi ce type de violent là
en réalité il est ultra minoritaire ans
et un sur dix là l'écrasante majorité
des victimes connaissent l'homme qu'il
est violent
moi je suis tombé dans cette case là
donc c'était plus facile à dire parce
que je savais que ça allait être plus
facile à entendre ça n'a pas empêché
qu'ils soient acquittés à l'arrivée ça
n'a pas empêché que j'en prenne par la
gueule mais enfin j'ai pu quand même en
parler j'ai pu porter plainte c'est à
dire dire à la société et dire devant
lui j'ai été violée et on n'a pas le
droit de me faire ça et c'est
fondamental pour la prêt pour ce pour se
reconstruire après j'ai pu dire j'ai pu
me remettre debout j'ai eu une mauvaise
violeur en revanche je ne compte pas le
nombre de fois où on m'a demandé si
l'individu était de type maghrébin alors
non non
et puis il était père de famille et puis
paie ses impôts sagelat entendu comme
argument le fait qu'il paye ses impôts
le rendrait inaptes à violer et puis il
était père de famille et puis il était
entraîneur d'une équipe de foot enfin
tout ça en faisait un comme nous et donc
lui non c'est intolérable il ne pouvait
pas avoir violées donc on l'a répété en
cour d'assises
il n'avait pas le profil du violeur la
réalité c'est qu'il n'y a pas de profil
de violeurs puisqu'en fait on viole dans
tous les milieux et à tous les âges
puisque c'est un système tout entier qui
est en cause et qui autorise le viol
voire qui a sa phase égard l'encouragent
je suis une mauvaise victime parce que
parce que ça ne se voit pas sur moi
parce que je ne correspond pas à l'idée
qu'on s'en fait parce que je ne suis pas
à terre parce que extérieurement je ne
porte pas je ne porte pas la marque de
la soudure ou de la faute si vous voulez
et parce que j'ai décidé de vivre malgré
tout j'ai tout fait pour que ça ne se
voit pas j'ai eu un premier cercle qui
était merveilleux et mes parents mes
soeurs mes amis qui m'ont cru qui m'a
entendu qui m'ont soutenu mais dès qu'on
sortait de ce premier cercle j'en
prenais plein la gueule donc j'ai fait
en sorte que ça ne se voit pas et puis
je croyais naïvement que j'allais
pouvoir limiter l'impact du viol c'est
de là que je me disais il m'a eu une
heure quarante
il aura rien de plus je vais reprendre
ma vie exactement comme avant
la vérité est un peu plus compliqué que
ça on a un petit peu plus de mal à
vendre avant de pouvoir marcher tout
droit mais donc j'ai parle je voulais
pas que ça se voit pour toutes ces
raisons là et en fait on l'a reproché en
cour d'assises le procureur a dû se
lever à un moment donné pour dire on ne
peut pas lui en vouloir d'avoir voulu
sauver sa peau cette nuit là et on peut
pas lui en vouloir aujourd'hui de
vouloir aller bien c'est à dire que
quand on est victime
si vous voulez être reconnu comme tel
alors il faut payer un tribut
et ça n'est pas qu'imagé jusqu'au 19ème
siècle et victimes ont été punis autant
que leurs violeurs aujourd'hui dans le
monde ça existe encore les femmes qu'on
lapide ou qu'on passe au vitriol parce
qu'elles ont été violées donc d'une
certaine manière comme dans l'esprit
dans la mémoire collective dans
l'inconscient collectif la culpabilité
est partagée va falloir qu'on paye comme
lui la réalité c'est que eux ne payent
pas au général puisque en france 1% des
viols seulement débouche sur une
condamnation par contre nous il faut
qu'on paye il faut compagne et donc il
faut que ça se voit et le prix à payer
c'est celui d'une vie à moitié mais moi
j'ai refusé ça j'ai refusé et c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles le
procès a débouché sur un sur un
acquittement
juste après le violent j'ai eu un
réflexe que toutes les victimes on sait
celui de me laver je voulais enlever
toutes les traces de lui sur moi je
voulais enlever cette odeur je voulais
relever ce que je sentais de lui encore
sur ma peau et que je ne supportais pas
évidemment donc je me suis précipité
pour prendre un bain et je me souviens
très bien d'ailleurs que c'était des
choses qu'on voyait à l'époque et qu'on
voit encore dans des téléfilms il ya une
espèce de séquences obligé où la victime
se lavent ce qu'on raconte pas après
c'est que du coup elle enlève les
preuves adn d'éventuelles preuves adn
peut-être j'en avais pas mais peut-être
qu'il y en avait donc faisant ça j'ai
tout nettoyer et en fait j'ai je voulais
effacer le souvenir de lui sur moi je
voulais face et le viol je me rendais
pas compte que j'étais en train
d'effacer des preuves
[Musique]
les femmes sont belles et bien décidé à
l'ouvrir à l'ouvrir pour de bon et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un
point où plus rien ne nous fera taire
plus rien mais encore une fois c'est bon
pour tout le monde parce qu'une société
qui met un couvercle sur ce qu'ils
déconnent chez elle c'est une société
qui se fige c'est une société qui peut
pas avancer c'est une société qui se
scléroser on a besoin de mobilité on a
besoin de discussion on a besoin même si
ça fait mal même si ça cogne on a besoin
d'eux de soulever le couvercle de
regarder les choses en face et d'en
parler donc peut-être que le moment est
venu passer à l'étape d'après de mieux
nommé les choses et de parler de
violences masculines
alors j'entends déjà tout le monde hurle
et en disant oui mais tous les hommes ne
viole pas alors je je veux bien
applaudir les hommes qui veulent pas
c'est juste la normalité en fait de ne
pas violer ces femmes le hashtag vous
savez à chaque fois qu'on dénonce des
violences sexuelles
on a un stade qui arrive qui est le
nôtre humaine
tous les hommes ne le font pas mais
encore heureux encore heureux et on va
pas encore une fois on va pas les
féliciter pour ça on va pas les
féliciter pour ne pas violer pour ne pas
pour ne pas frapper pour ne pas harceler
pour ne pas agresser
c'est une perte de temps gigantesque si
à chaque fois qu'on parle de viol il
faut échanger même trois tweets ou
occupé même une minute de temps
d'antenne pour rappeler que nous tous
les hommes ne viole pas on perd un temps
fou
on le sait tous les hommes ne viole pas
tous les hommes ne harcèle pas tous les
hommes ne bat pas leurs femmes on le
sait est ce que une fois que c'est dit
on peut s'intéresser à ceux qui le font
et voir comment on peut faire en sorte
qu'il ne le fasse plus la parole et
s'est déjà libéré 1 ça fait des années
qu'on parle c'est juste qu'on veut pas
nous entendre l'enjeu il n'est pas dans
qui parle
il est dans qui entend est-ce qu'on va
enfin se déboucher les oreilles
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ces paroles
de ces témoignages de ces récits
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire et pas très compliqué
reste à savoir quand est-ce qu'on les
fait quand est-ce qu'on passe la seconde
en fait je parle de formation des flics
je parle de formation des médecins je
parle de formation des juges je parle de
crédits alloués à des associations de
lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
j'ai part la touche il n'y a pas c'est
pas très compliqué en fait on quand
est-ce qu'on le fait